hey guys Pete here I've been having a
lot of conflicting comments about
whether or not Daenerys can have
children and I realized I wasn't exactly
sure where the shows version of events
have left this off I know what happened
in Daenerys is last chapter in the books
but things aren't always the same so I
decided to try and get to the bottom of
it so when I don't know something I look
it up and this is kind of interesting
and I figured I just make a video about
it because so many people are asking
about this there's a spoiler warning
here the whole idea of this is based on
some things that were said in Game of
Thrones season 7 episode 6 so if you're
not caught up this could be spoiling and
now you've been warned so there's been a
lot of talk because it's pretty obvious
that Jon and Daenerys are going to be
getting together in the show in one way
or another I made a couple videos about
that so I'm not going to get into any of
that here but it's important because the
show's made it important in the last
episode about whether or not she can
have children there wasn't just one
reference to this but there were a
couple first she told Jon that the
dragons were her children and she says
they're the only children I'll ever have
do you understand
so as far as the Narus is concerned she
cannot have children
Tyrion also brought this up in the same
episode because he was talking about
that lineage and the succession if
something would happen to her he says
how do we ensure your vision indoors
after you break the wheel how do we make
sure it stays broken you say you can't
have children but there are other ways
of choosing a successor so those were
the main points but are they right or
not that's the question and the reason
why I would ask that in the first place
is because like I said in the books it
appears that this situation has changed
and as far as I could remember the book
in the show weren't exactly on the same
page like what the Miriam has door stuff
so that's where we'll start
the reason why Danny doesn't think she
can have children is because of
something that Mary mazdoor said you
remember way back it happened
whenever called Drogo was dying and she
wanted to save his life she ends up
asking the maid to eat
Miri mazdoor to save him and basically
goes against everybody else's wishes as
no one thinks that this woman is trusted
marry mazdoor warns her though that only
death can pay for life but it's safe to
say that she tricked her because the way
it was set up
Daenerys thought she was going to have
to kill the horse and that was going to
be enough to turn Khal Drogo's life
around this was not the case though
because when Daenerys leaves she starts
to get ill like you know she knows
something's wrong she's pregnant at the
time of course with their unborn child
Rago and she eventually passes out or
collapses and we don't see her again
until she is waking up Dora then tells
her that Rago died when she was giving
birth the mare is asked to see what it
was that paid for that she paid for I
should say with her son's life and she
finds out that Drogo isn't exactly
himself like he's alive but he's
basically a walking vegetable she is
upset of course he says this is not life
and she asked when will he be as he was
marry mazdoor says when the Sun rises in
the West and sets in the east when the
Seas go dry and the mountains blow in
the wind like leaves now this is the
part that I remembered being different
in the book it's the same more or less
but it says at the end when your womb
quickens again and you bear a living
child then he will return and not before
so this is something that Daenerys
thinks about all the time and the books
the words that minimized or said to her
even though the show cut it out that's
still kind of like where everybody was
with this and it's come up a couple of
times and regardless of anything else
Daenerys thinks that her dragons are her
children because they're the only
children she will ever have
at one point she actually says something
about this to Dora that they are her
children and he basically says what they
are
actually your children they didn't grow
inside of your womb you know you didn't
breastfeed them when they were small but
that is the way that she sees them
there's even a interview that was in one
of the DVDs I think or one of those
behind-the-scenes kind of interviews
where Emilia Clarke says this is one of
Danny's driving motivations basically
she knows this is it the only family
she's ever going to have
so I mentioned it really quickly because
it is in the big picture of things in
her last chapter in the book something
happens with Daenerys that's most likely
a miscarriage now that's as far as she's
gotten her story so we don't really know
anything else about it in there you know
she still be she's still not even past
the part where the fighting pit stuff
happens so we can't really compare the
two but we do know that that was a part
of her story and that while she may not
be able to carry a child to term at
least she has regained the ability to
conceive in the books and there's
arguments on both sides but I kind of
end up at the point of like why is it
there if it's not to mean something so
it wouldn't be a total shock if in the
show she also regained that ability one
of the most interesting things that I
read when I was looking into this though
was that even though Mary mazdoor left
that part out in the show's version
Daenerys actually did say this at one
point she's talking to Cowell Morrow and
she says I will not lie with you and I
will bury you no children or anyone else
not until the Sun rises in the West and
set in the east so it's interesting that
they put it back in there and that was
in season six it could just be a nod to
the books but if we just go off of what
is there I mean she says it as in this
is a part of her leap system so what
does it all mean is it really important
it is absolutely important and Tyrion
brought it up because she's trying to
take over Westeros of course she
believes that she has a birthright to do
so but with the right of conquest and
everything else I mean you still have to
people back you because if no one backs
you then eventually someone will come
along and that'll get set up so they
take you out of power having an air is
super important and if people would find
out that she was unable to produce an
air that would set up a lot of problems
as far as having support since she is a
woman she can't solve this problem just
through marriage a marriage has to also
involved an heir now all of this may not
really matter in the long run anyways
because as most people I do believe that
the Iron Throne itself will be pointless
at the end but it doesn't make the lead
up to that part any different no one in
Westeros right now really thinks maybe
except for Jon Snow and Davos that none
of the stuff in the South matters this
is why I pointed out that I thought that
Tyrion bringing this up to her was
probably one of the most important parts
in episode six because a leader needs to
have a line of succession when she went
beyond the wall to get into this battle
to save the Magnificent Seven she could
have been killed just as easily as
anyone else this could also cause
problems because Jon now has been
confirmed as a legitimate Targaryen and
like I said in that past video about the
last Targaryen this would actually
strengthen his claim even though we know
that John's dead and came back to life
and that might mean that he can't have
children
he doesn't really go around advertising
this and until he actually tested it out
no one really knows for sure because
there's really not precedent out there
about people who come back to life not
being able to have children so you would
think that if people wanted to be
against an heiress they could use that
in their way to get the person they want
if that happened to be Jon Snow into
power rather than her and of course this
is all leading to them getting together
anyways in my opinion at this point so
it's also important in that way can they
produce an heir together it's
interesting when you think about it
because she's probably wrong about
believing the prophecy just because
that's usually how
it goes like there's something to
prophecy in this world for sure but most
of the times we see it play out it plays
out in that people misinterpret and mess
something up majorly because they're
trying to follow a prophecy it's more
clear in the books but I mean if you
need any kind of nod in that direction
think about Shireen Baratheon Stannis
and his wife would have never decided
that it would be a good idea to burn her
at the stake if it wasn't for prophecy
right so yeah so one way or the other
whether she can't have an heir or she
can't it puts up some interesting stuff
out there to think about
if she can't that really does bring to
the forefront the idea that she has to
have an idea that she can sell as a way
to pass on her power after she passes
away I've read a lot of interesting
things about that over the last couple
days and it's really just the subject of
another video because it's just too much
to go into here but based on what we've
seen it looks like this is something
that we should know and the TLDR here is
Daenerys doesn't think she can have a
child but we really don't know if we use
the books as an example of what might
come then there's a pretty good chance
that she will be able to conceive but we
won't know until we know please like
this video if you enjoyed it make sure
you subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already after you subscribe you
got to turn on notifications because
that's the best way to find out when new
videos are out also follow me on twitter
and my other social media accounts
because i'm pretty active over there and
thanks for watching guys I'll talk to
you soon